if you're at home you're an entrepreneur
you're a small business startup
you're not spending time and money don't
call yourself an entrepreneur
because by definition you're not a lot
of people think 10x is
oh all the time you're 10x sometimes 10x
means i got to contract again
get rid of some stuff so i can double
down or 10x on the things that are
working
my success is dependent upon the hate
and the criticism and the rejection
you got to have it it's part of the it's
part of the recipe of success
unfortunately
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation top
and 10. and men
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are you
are the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best grant cardone and my take on his
top 10 rules for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one be brutally honest
if you're at home you're an entrepreneur
you're a small business startup
you're not spending time and money don't
call yourself an entrepreneur
because by definition you're not i'm
going to be back here in november and
there's going to be people that will not
spend the money
because they don't have the money that's
what they're saying i don't have the
money so i can't spend it
to come spend a couple days with me
there's so many ways to get the money
yeah exactly so so an entrepreneur says
hey
entrepreneur entrepreneurs by definition
don't make excuses
okay you want to come to the growth
conference and figure out how to come i
know it's
an excuse that i shouldn't say to myself
and
like if you make excuses that's one
thing but don't be don't make excuses
and become a liar exactly you know like
you said
be honest do at least say look i made an
excuse i didn't come to the deal didn't
make it work don't don't be i make
excuses and i'll out of myself right so
exactly
um the entrepreneur needs to get
brutally brutally honest with themselves
and with their family and get
participation from the family unit
rule number two embrace hate handling
kind of criticism and people saying
don't do that or you can't do that
because you know
on any kind of success journey you do
get a lot of that what how did you kind
of
handle that yeah you know in the
beginning you're not ready for
i was not ready for the amount of
um criticism you know first you're going
to be ignored
in the beginning you're just going to be
ignored nobody's going to even pay
attention to you you could be jesus
you could walk on water and they're
gonna ignore you nobody will even see
hey did you see that did you take a
selfie
did you get it on instagram if you
didn't it didn't happen so it doesn't
matter like you could literally save the
world and if nobody saw it
they're gonna ignore you in the
beginning then they're going to reject
you
third thing they're going to do is
they're going to criticize you make fun
of you
but if you stay with it they're going to
adopt it okay i mean brilliant people
are adopted at the end
if they just stay with the hate along
the way is part of the game
for you to get past being ignored and
then rejected you will be hated on
and once you start accumulating enough
success
uh we we were i told my team over here
we got 155 employees i'm like guys look
you have to be ready it's coming the
criticism
the stuff online don't even look at it
it's all garbage
and if it affects you negatively
it's not about what they're saying it's
about what it does to you personally
i just know it's part of the game now in
the beginning i wasn't ready for it now
i understand oh
my success is dependent upon the hate
and the criticism and the rejection
you got to have it it's part of the it's
part of the recipe of success
unfortunately because people that quit
are
going to hate you for not quitting
they're actually not talking about you
they're
talking about themselves and they're
like he's wrong for having a damn plane
because they quit on their plane
everybody can have a plane
the crazy is everybody can have
everything they want because there's
enough to go around for everybody
so uh for every guy that doesn't have
what he wants there's somebody on this
planet that has the oceanfront house
that goes on as many trips as they want
some guy that's got the 200-foot yacht
some guy that funded a hospital
somewhere and put his name on it
and and you know it's just crazy
that the hate always comes from the same
place a quitter
haters actually on haters they're
quitters rule number three
be omnipresent what are your best three
marketing tips
uh to number one is be everywhere all at
the same time
it's called omnipresence so
omnipresence anything that's the
omnipresence by the way has survived for
since the beginning of man 300 000 years
or whatever
whoever can be everywhere will be
assigned power
whether it's the queen or god or
coca-cola
whatever can be everywhere will be
assigned
power and so omnipresence with marketing
this has really never been possible
before until
the digital age the last six or seven
years
facebook instagram snapchat youtube
these things that
based on the age of this audience half
of you probably don't use
you know because you're like i don't
have time for that this well-dressed man
right here with the sweater
and the glasses over his nose and this
man this man this very aristocratic
looking gentleman okay he are you on
facebook sir
he's on facebook that's unbelievable
instagram
no youtube i mean you have a youtube
channel
i don't mean you watch my youtube
you have your own youtube channel okay
that's pretty good
so but but but you see like like you
should the answer to your question is be
omnipresent two use all channels
all of them everything i'm gonna use
youtube snapchat
linkedin twitter i'm going to use
newspapers even though
most people aren't reading newspapers
i'm going to use magazines i'm going to
use
that's that's marketing i'm gonna use
expo events like this
events like stages like this i'm gonna
use telephone calls
cold calling warm calling i'm gonna use
billboards if you go to miami right now
you'll see 28 massive billboards
throughout
miami a million dollars worth of
marketing material where
i'm introducing where i live
the business owners to my name so i
would use
every um marketing
means possible lastly the number three
thing
is i would have your marketing budget
be have a target
of your last year's income
i would spend more money on marketing
than i do people and i would spend more
money on people than than i could even
imagine i would just spend more money
rule number four keep attacking there
was this book written called
the millionaire next door it was a big
sensation too a lot of people read this
book it was a super super hit big hit
book okay
and when i read the book i was like i
got something different from it than
what other people got from it other
people were like okay i'm not i'm not
going to coffee shops anymore okay i'm
not going to buy a brand new car anymore
what i got was i don't want to be the
millionaire next door
that's what i got from the book so it's
all about your viewpoint right when
when i finished reading the book i was
like okay i don't want to be a
millionaire
and i'm definitely not going to take
advice from a millionaire because when
you get a million dollars if you
if you came from if you came up the way
you and i did
and you had nothing i give you a million
dollars and you're going to think
dude oh my god i've got a million
dollars your mom's gonna kiss you oh
he's done i always knew you could make
it right
uh and then and then and then you're
gonna wake up the next morning and say
dude i don't want to lose this money you
go into conservation
into defense you start playing defense i
was with mike tyson i did
mike tyson's podcast the the boxer right
well in
19 years old mike was a champion of the
world yeah
when mike got in the ring man in in when
he was
at his perfection he didn't hit you once
he hit you and he kept hitting you until
you went down there was
attack attack attack attack attack
attack attacking two you couldn't get up
two you're like you're just gonna
even if the body can get up you're like
i don't want to get up now because i
can't win this
and that is the way people should be
attacking life right
when mike started getting data i even
told him this said dude when you went to
the therapist
when you started therapy is when you
started having problems
grant you're right grant quinn you're
right
when you stop seeing the therapist you
got better because the therapist puts
you on defense what are you doing
you start going on defense you start
looking at where you made your mistakes
as opposed to saying
hey dude what worked let's repeat it
let's don't do destructive stuff
yeah let's get rid of whatever's driving
the destructive behavior right
but with money man with money what you
want to do is you want to double down
yeah this is why the casinos never never
you know get broke because nobody bets
enough in the casinos
if all the whales showed up in macau
or in in right here in london or in
vegas and all the whales showed up
at one weekend and said hey we're gonna
break the bank and we're gonna all push
in hard
they could take down the casino but
because all the little guys go to the
bay
they they lose five they lose five they
lose five they win
fifteen they say i'm out of here yeah
okay if they break even they think they
had a big night
hey man everybody how you doing buddy
good how are you you got a book coming
out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five build a team
people are like oh bigger is not better
and you know i'm better off by myself
you are not better off by yourself
it is absolutely impossible to live on
planet earth
as one person try to communicate the 7
billion
and think you're going to stay in the
game you're not it's impossible so you
solopreneurs out there
your business model that you created is
already broken
thinking i'm going to be by myself and
do it by myself and the proof is in the
pudding because
there's 28 million small businesses in
america 22 million of them
uh break even or lose money those 22
million all have one thing in common
no employees no support rule number six
study successful people i made the
mistake in my life
of studying people that appeared to be
successful
a lot of people are like that they
appeared to be successful you know today
today in the the the the times that we
live in you know you can go on instagram
it looks like
looks like everybody owns a ferrari
everybody has a rolls royce
everybody looks like they're having the
best day of their life
that's not studying that's watching i
want to study people
or even even at conferences you can go
to a conference and watch somebody on
stage
and he could he he or she could present
to like they're so successful but
if you really get behind the scenes
you'll find out there is no success
there it's just a lot of talking
and so i would just strongly suggest to
people to
pick a handful of people and make sure
those people are actually
doing not just saying
you know that they're they're not
talking about success they're actually
doing success every day
and how would you know what they're
doing well you should you would you
would see it in their statistics right
like there's some things you can't fake
yeah you can't fake somebody
uh we're buying 250 million worth of
real estate this month
with my money hard to fake that okay
it's a great instagram post by the way
but you can't fake it
there's going to be a loan there's going
to be a building there's going to be
you know acres and acres of land there's
going to be
people living there like you just can't
fake it so there's a lot of things you
can
fake you know you can make a nice little
quote put it on instagram
people look at it like that's the truth
you know and and uh
the public is is confused with a lot of
what appears to be the truth
it's not that's right and so i would
just tell people
um study people
that have success that are doing it now
also the second thing i would say is
make sure that where you're getting your
advice from them
lines up with where you need advice
right so
warren buffett you know warren buffett
he he's at the
he's at the he's at the tail um
he he's at the tail of his of his
he's probably here right so
here he was doing different things than
he's doing here he he talks about
investing in stocks but he actually
doesn't do it
he doesn't buy stocks he buys companies
yeah uh so you gotta you gotta listen to
people steve jobs right here was one of
the most aggressive
business people that this plan has ever
seen i mean he was barbarian
aggressive so was bill gates but if you
talk to bill gates today
bill and steve steve's not alive
obviously but bill gates today saying
dude i'm giving all my money away money
doesn't matter that's not what he was
saying right here
rule number seven double down on what's
working
right now in 2020 here we are in april
right we have this
covida thing happen and we have massive
unemployment worldwide
literally a worldwide recession if not a
depression about
in formation right now this is not the
time for me to go try something new
this is the time for me to double down
on what's working how to help people
right now
how do i scale cardone university how do
i help customers
i need to actually contract a second
so that i could pull the forces back
and prepare for another assault yeah
you can't just go run out like a lot of
people think 10x is
oh all the time you're 10x sometimes 10x
means i gotta contract again
get rid of some stuff so i can double
down or 10x on the things that are
working
so i can move again and set up that
other company that i want
uh to to for instance the real estate
i can't go expand my real estate
portfolio in this environment today
not because i don't want to but because
the markets have seized up
i need a second i need a second for
things to relieve themselves
uh to to in order to go back and
go from 7 000 units to 14 000 units
rule number eight have the right
investment priorities
property's been a big part of your
career in investing in property
what you know can you just give us an
insight into do you still think that
that's a good investment for people i
know you've been on record as saying you
know
it's not a good idea to to to own your
own house that kind of thing what where
you know
what what are your views on the current
uh property market so
so the issue the issue for property
again i love real estate you know
we buy real estate every day every day
i'm trying to buy some real estate
but the problem is priorities people
guy gets out of school gets married
husband and wife
oh we got to buy a house that is the
wrong first thing to do
like why are you buying a house we need
a place to live that's an investment a
house is not an investment
a business is an investment
going to dinner with a client that is an
investment
going on a trip to meet with other great
people that could become investors or
customers
that's an investment buying a house a
place to live
and the banks the banks years ago the
banks
convinced the public that
a house is an investment a house is not
an investment
so why are people notice how many of
your friends bought a house but they
have invested money in their
in their in their business they bought a
house but they didn't invest money in
making themselves done
dude i am the house it's the grant
cardone house
okay where i live does it really matter
to me it could be the rich hotel it
could be the four seasons it could be
the marriott
it could be your house i could go bunk
up at your place
the investments people should be making
is number one in myself
number two is in my business and the
third thing they should buy
once they got the first two handled
everybody should start trying to invest
in real assets or real estate that pays
them i'm not talking about a house i'm
talking about
buy buy a piece of real estate that
other people
rent from you so that you get cash flow
rule number nine build a warrior culture
how do you build a business with a
strong base of operations you talk a lot
about sales and marketing
but how how do we do it that sales and
marketing go into a strong base of
operations and process
how do you go what advice would you give
an entrepreneur to build that
strong you need a strong culture you
have to have a strong culture and the
culture starts with the leadership right
so
if i'm trying to teach and this is what
happens in big companies
and causes big companies to fail is the
ceo often
is not really connected to what's
happening on the ground
and um it's one of the reasons we've
been so successful in america
crowdfunding
yes against conglomerates culture
is the leadership calls out the people
around him it keeps everybody sharp
exactly or you have a culture where
everybody's asleep
exactly you have culture either way it's
like what culture do you want
you want warriors and fighters and
acquirers
and people that are hungry and never
satisfied or do you have a
a culture we just left the meeting and
they're like
we got problems here people are
satisfied
or and not working hard enough there's a
handful of people that are extremely
aggressive here
but for the most part the the woman told
me most people
are just making excuses not going to the
next level
not taking the action saying this or
that about this or that
that's the reason why this or that is
this this or that right
and and so you got to build a culture of
no excuses
means you got to bring hire people and
get rid of people
we met with some real estate agents
yesterday they hired a thousand
sales people for this project they're
doing 10 10
10 billion worth of real estate to sell
they want me to sell it all
i said yeah i can do that so i'm sorry
and and um a thousand sales people now
they're down to a couple hundred i said
dude you don't
call you you you you have to get a
strong culture
he's like we don't have any culture i
said oh yeah you do you
you on board people and then you don't
train them and educate them
and they make sure that they're excited
and keep with them you can't go to an
event for three days get excited
and think it's going to last three weeks
later it's it's not
that's got to be instilled into the
culture you know you look around
these buildings the way these buildings
there's reinforced steel there's
concrete there's glass there's
blue like some something's holding that
thing together
the birds where i'm staying it's holding
it together
long after it's built and that that's
what has to happen with management and
ownership
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is understand
the 10x way of life can you walk through
the 10x rule like i know you sort of
touched on points but like just high
level just because some people
may not know like you're known as the
10x guy but what is a 10x
rule at its core yeah well the 10x rule
first of all the 10x rule is not an idea
it's a way of life
and and people that go 10x are massive
action people and and the premise of the
book is there's four levels of action
there's you don't do anything
you retreat you do average
or you go 10x now the first three the
first
three we everybody knows somebody that
does nothing
that you call them lazy actually it's
impossible
to do nothing but but just for
conversation we'll say a person does
nothing
we know that's not gonna work going
retreating
if you retreat your entire lifetime it's
going to be very painful
retreating by the way is actually takes
more energy
than just normal activity just the guys
that get up every day and go to work
every day
going backwards making a decision to do
something and not doing it is
very painful a lot of wear and tear
going backwards
the third the third one is the most
damaging of all three which is
normal levels of activity the acceptable
the average the the middle class the
norm
because you get lost these people get
lost they work every day they show up
every day they dig ditches every day
they do a good job every day they're
loyal every day
but they never get rewarded ever uh
number three is the story of my whole
life that's where i operated
the most of my life most people normal
levels of activity
maybe just above normal just enough to
shine a little bit but dude i never went
for it
and and and so the 10x rule is like okay
how do i
really take some risk here how do i
really put myself out there
uh so the middle class of america
is basically laid up on number three
being convinced to go to number two
and then end up with basically they'll
end up with number one
and how do you suggest somebody takes
that
move from three to four yeah so you what
you would what you would do is you
you need to understand that number three
is is the
the biggest disaster that we have it's
where
all wealth is created on the backs of
number three
uh the the the wealthy the wealthy
and this will happen again we'll come
out of this
this virus thing people will go back to
consuming again
and they'll go back to debt they'll go
back to borrowing money to buy things
they don't even need to impress people
they don't even know because they're
unsure about who they are and where
they're going
and so the the middle the middle of the
the spine of america the spine the
middle class of india when it develops
the middle class of china will fund the
wealthy
and because they do the normal things
the wealth wealthy do not do normal
things they do completely
you know they they do they don't they
don't save money wealthy people don't
save money they invest money wealthy
people don't spend time or manage time
they they they take money that's useless
they know it's useless
and they buy i'm gonna get a thousand
employees
and then everybody's like well you know
that guy never works he hired 1 000
people to do work
this is an old story by the way you can
go back to the king tut
okay i mean it's it's it's not a new
story it's like how do you get wealthy
well you commit to massive action how do
you do massive action
you only have 40 hours a week or 80 or
100.
uh elon musk says hey man 100 hours he
works 100 hours a week he
he does the video about the 100 hours
he's like look if i do 100 and you do 40
i win
he's a smart dude too by the way real
smart guy but he's nobody without the
risk
without the big think and without the
massive action
now i've got a very special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get motivated
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through but when you get
motivated
inspired and you create a plan of action
you have a
over 90 chance of following through and
when you share with other people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood of
following through and so i want that to
be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you when i
was 25 years old i had
i was broke no money i had no respect
for my family
i was the black sheep i was in debt
i had lost seven jobs when i quit
blaming everyone else
my life changed when i quit looking at
what everybody else had
and said why do they have that and i
don't and when i shifted at them
why don't they why do they have all that
stuff and i don't when i finally made
the little shift
and asked the same question why did they
have it and i don't what have they done
that i haven't done
what do they know that i don't know what
moves did they make that i didn't make
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there